ah le chant des baleines c'est
particulièrement relaxant oui sauf que
ce qu'entendent les ballets ne sait pas
exactement ça hein
il ya quand même toute une partie en
ultrasons et en infrasons une équipe de
chercheurs de montpellier nous apprend
que cette sensibilité aux infra et aux
ultrasons est apparu très tard dans
l'histoire évolutive des baleines et
c'est ce caillou qui nous le dit ce
caillou est un morceau fossilisés de
l'oreille dans protos est une sorte
d'ancêtre des baleines et des dauphins
bon en fait la chercheure m'a dit qu'il
fallait mieux dire le cousin de
l'ancêtre commun des baleines et des
dauphins
il vivait il y à 45 millions d'années et
il avait des petites pape
et oui ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ses descendants les
baleines à dents comme les orques ou les
dauphins utilisent les ultras sont donc
trop aiguë pour l'oreille humaine pour
se localiser un peu comme les sonars de
nous sous marins al'inverse les baleines
à bosse utilisent les infrasons donc
dans les graves
cette fois ci pour communiquer sur de
longues distances
revenons à notre proto 7 ils entendaient
quoi lui en regardant le fossile comme
ça on ne peut pas déduire grand chose
donc
les chercheurs ont scanné avec une
technique appelée micro tomographie à
rayons x
cela leur a permis de voir d'infimes
différences de densité entre l' os
fossilisés et la pierre et voilà comment
on passe d'un caillou à la
reconstitution 3d de l'oreille interne
d'un animal qui vivait il y à 45
millions d'années et ce sans abîmer le
précieux fossiles les chercheurs ont
ensuite montré qu'avec une telle qu clé
c'est le nom de l'organe principal de
l'audition notre proto 7 ne pouvait
entendre ni ultrasons me infrasons comme
nous par contre il pouvait entendre à la
fois sur terre et dans l'eau ce qui
correspond bien à un mode de vie
amphibie la capacité à entendre les
infrasons où les ultrasons serait donc
apparu plus tard une fois que les
baleines sont devenus des animaux 100%
apathique
cette découverte laisse donc entendre
que l'histoire évolutive des cétacés
serait bien plus complexe qu'on ne
l'imaginait voilà donc le chant des
baleines
à l'époque ça devait ressembler à un peu
autre chose
[Musique]
abonnez vous